when he broke the sign in dodger stadium
during batting practice i went in this
is a playoff game
i went in i said hey i need some dodger
letterhead i had it typed up hey on
behalf of the los angeles dodgers we are
finding you ten thousand dollars for
breaking the sign
someone and i put it on his chair and he
looked at he goes what should i do now
this is
30 minutes before the first pitch yeah
yeah yeah you got to pay it
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today
what's going on man curtis granted
what's good with you baby man i'm all
good appreciate you having me here hey
man it's good chopping up with you let's
see how you break down let's see how
nice you are let's see
all right
so where'd you start off high or what
like start off in short season a okay in
oneonta new york small town i remember
my scout that drafted me jerome cochran
said man you're gonna love it it's
beautiful up there it's a ton of trees
and everything it was a lot of trees but
there wasn't nothing else up there oh
man i mean we've seen a lot in terms of
the minor leagues you got people who are
coming from the dominican venezuela and
they're also coming through the same
ranks as you talk about how did you
assimilate with all these different
people from all these different cultures
that you've probably never been open or
experienced to you know growing up in
chicago even though i had sammy sosa
playing for the cubs or ozzie guillen
player for the white sox this is a
little hey don't get mad at me sammy
don't get mad at me ozzy i thought they
were black
right they looked like me they were
playing baseball i thought sammy sosa
was black i had never seen no one with
the last name sosa before i just thought
it was a different last name when i
joined my team the first time i remember
getting on the bus i said man it's the
most black players i've ever played with
now remember again i'm coming from work
thinking ozzy's black thinking sammy's
black so i see everyone that looked like
me and i go what's going on how you
doing you know hello hello how's
everybody doing what's going on and no
one's saying anything so now i get in
the back of the bus the bus starts going
the music starts playing now i started
hearing the latin music
latin dominican venezuelan and i
realized that although we look very
similar we're still slightly different
and then that started that process of
understanding okay there's a whole
different world out there besides
chicago where i grew up and i wanted to
learn it i wanted to take it in and i
was excited to get a chance to be on
that team to start my career
there we go so i've been in clubhouse
before i've covered baseball teams and
it's always been interesting to me being
in a clubhouse knowing that there's
probably gonna be two leaders in a
clubhouse one of them who's a leader for
the latin players
and the other one who's like the english
speaking leader
and most of the time let's be honest
it's probably a white dude
as a black man how did you fit in this
dynamic when you're trying to figure out
where you fit in as a black man in the
baseball team we were the minority so i
think that helped us kind of be right in
the middle of both sides and i think
both of them knew okay cool we're we're
here for for you if you need us we're
here for you if you need us you need us
to translate and bring it over here to
make you feel a little more comfortable
we can do that how can they play in the
music so loud we like it loud too okay
let me tell them turn it down i'll tell
them turn it down a little bit okay why
they always listen to the country and
and cowboys
that's what they like too you know and
then here we go i got your intercessors
man he probably the countries
latin cuban dude
he rode to the stadium on a horse
on a horse not a car not a bike on a
horse a new roller horse
and buckled so big and still got the
neon yellow sleeves on like so imagine
that neon yellow sleeve
hit home runs and ride a horse at the
same man so if this dude wasn't fitting
in with everybody who else could
my shot here let's see where we at where
we at i think you got it oh man it's
gonna be a tight one there you go there
you go let's go get legs there we go
there we go you talked a lot about
clubhouse camaraderie and clubhouse
chemistry how was that one the 2015 mets
team so that team i think had no
standout player suspicious was probably
the biggest one but he still was getting
his wings underneath him right david
wright was coming off an injury michael
cadyer had just come to us but he was
for the twins and a lot of people didn't
watch the twins that much we started
rolling
daniel murphy has probably the best
playoffs i've ever seen that's not the
guy you were trying to not let beat you
right is anyone accounting for that or
not
i don't think anyone saw that coming i
mean we go into wrigley field and he's
hitting the balls left and right all
over the place and then in dodger
stadium that first round dude is
breaking signs and batting practice
and the thing about duda is he's just so
quiet and so calm and reserved but again
we're locker mates and we both bat
left-handed so we had so many things in
common so i always mess with them and
here comes the we follow lucas duda
instagram page tell me about that yeah
man how'd that come together he was
starting to get hot that year i think he
hit 30 home runs and i was like dude you
got to be on social media no no no i
don't like social media i don't want any
of that and we took a picture of him and
created the page that was it we didn't
expect anything else and that page got
to 100 000 followers like this so now it
became our whole team was all trying to
stalk him and just catch him in
different moments when he broke the sign
in dodger stadium during batting
practice i went in this is a playoff
game
this is just where my mind is i want to
keep everybody loose
i went in i said hey i need some dodger
letterhead on a piece of paper so i got
dodger letterhead i had it typed up hey
on behalf of the los angeles dodgers we
are finding you ten thousand dollars for
breaking the sign
someone said i put it on his chair and
he looked at he goes what should i do
now this is
30 minutes before the first pitch yeah
yeah yeah what do you think i should do
with this
you got to pay it
you got it
and he went out there and had a great
series dude did a great series we beat
the dodgers in dodger stadium so little
things like that just to keep everybody
loose the we follow lucas duda instagram
account all that stuff i think just
helped play into it all and we kept
going and then once we got to the world
series we just came up a little bit
short there
that first game in kansas city we were
up alex gordon hits a home run to put it
in the extras
not
losing that game but going to new york
down 0-2 versus going to new york one to
one because i think we were going to
lose the second game they played really
well that puts us in a different
situation because everyone says game
three is the turning point and we won
game three then it was just playing
ketchup at that point in time and we ran
out of juice yeah you know the city
field the blue and orange the seven line
the homer's out of the ballpark we just
came up a little short but i wouldn't
trade anything
from that season it was great because no
one expected and that's what you want to
be expect the unexpected so take your
shot right we got insurance on the place
right are we good i think so okay all
right good then we might i may try you
know what dude let me try it yeah let me
try let's see what you can do
there we go
[Music]
i curtis your real childhood passion
with basketball man i wanted to hoop for
as long as i could but you can see the
height just didn't
it slowed down for a little bit well
let's see how nice you were on the papa
shot is that cool let's do that 60
seconds gonna hit the button come on
bring it down i'm gonna ask you
questions all the time it's gonna be
fast all right let's go who are you
listening to before a game okay
mezza yankees mets
hardest pitcher to hit off of red hand
funniest opponent you've played
uh sean casey
a-rod or cheater favorite wrestler
junkyard dog
best slugger in baseball miguel cabrera
queens or the bronx
bronx i'll get my haircut boogie down
you guys they're going to cut your hair
there's a phone in your face
best mlb mascot
mr met
one player former current you wish you
could have played jackie robins
funniest teammate you've had by the
total cologne
chewing gum or sunflowers
worst fans in baseball
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the fans they booed santa claus
from what i heard back philly fans are
terrible that's a great one to pick but
he didn't throw batteries at me
curtis appreciate you coming to fulham
man thank you for having me i appreciate
you all for watching
[Music]